the media is going after him and why are
they going after him because all he's
doing is saying hey I'm just trying to
make sure we can respect Free Speech a
little bit more on Twitter what a
freaking headache he chose to get
involved in he could have gotten his
family on a rocket and gone to Mars
instead he's fighting for our mortal
lives here on planet Earth but they're
very upset with him because somehow to
the left and to the machine as it
operates
Free Speech me is somehow a a connection
to the alt-right and mean people on the
right I think free speech is just about
the marketplace of ideas and good ideas
will win out over time but I'm old
school Elon tweeted this because he's
not happy with what's going on here
because he's getting hit hard and it's
and it's hitting Twitter's bottom line
uh Apple has mostly stopped advertising
on Twitter do they hate free speech in
America
what's going on here Tim Cook Tim Cook
of course is the CEO of Apple and then
Jonathan Chait same guy who I just
referenced a moment ago for going after
DeSantis in something that had nothing
to do with DeSantis he wrote try posting
more conspiracy theories and white
supremacist memes that ought to bring
them back okay so first off Elon Musk
has not posted any white supremacist
memes this is complete nonsense and the
idea that somehow Twitter can't be a
place where people share conspiracy
theories well I don't know Donald Trump
very fine people on both sides Brett
Kavanaugh as a serial rapist uh you know
all this stuff right we could we could
literally just go through these all day
the Jesse Smollett Oaks all of these
things the covid shots work masks work
lockdowns work this has all been pushed
by the power structure they were pushing
lies and conspiracy theories now there's
a little bit of pushback and giant
corporations are pulling ads out of
Twitter because of that even though
Twitter's usage is now at an all-time
high Ai and apple is considering at
least some people are reporting apple is
considering booting Twitter off the app
store which is crazy oh it's absolutely
crazy so it's not just that Elon bought
Twitter and is expanding Free Speech
it's that he's exposing the left and I
don't want to just say the left here
it's he's exposing the power structure
the cultural norms of corporate press
and and all of the the journalistic
outlets he's he's exposing them for what
they are they are tyrants they are the
machine and they're losing a bit of
control